- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
Welcome to this Homeroom live stream,
as always, I'm very excited
about the conversation
we're going to have with our guest today,
Representative Karen Bass.
But before we get to that,
I'll give my standard announcements.
First of all, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit
organization, we only exist
through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself,
if you're in a position to do so.
So if you can, please think about going
to Khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations
that have been helping
to support Khan Academy,
especially as we've gone
through the COVID crisis.
We were already running at
a deficit before the crisis,
and you could imagine
the load on our servers
has been a two and a
half, three times normal,
registrations have been
more than 10 times normal,
we've been trying to accelerate
a whole series of content
and product and programmatic elements,
and to help us there, special
thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly, Novartis,
and actually the Amgen Foundation
and the many other supporters
of Khan Academy over the years
that have really put us in
a position to be able to do
the work that we're able
to do now to support
so many folks through this
difficult time period.
I also wanna remind folks that
if you've enjoyed watching
these Homeroom live streams,
or maybe you haven't had
a chance to watch as many,
and you would just like
to listen to some of
them, this live stream
is adapted for podcasts now,
and so you can find Homeroom
with Sal the Podcast,
anywhere that you would
typically find your podcasts.
So with that, I'm excited
to introduce Representative Karen Bass,
member of the US House of Representatives
representing the 33rd
district of California,
former speaker of the California Assembly,
chair of the House Black Caucus.
Thanks for joining us Representative Bass.
- Thanks for having me on,
nice to be with you today.
- So there's a bunch of stuff,
I'm super eager to cover with you.
First of all, your life's journey
I think is very inspirational,
so I wanna go into that.
A lot of young people kind
of trying to figure out
what to do with life.
I think the second element is,
where it's some major
milestones in history
or at least anniversaries of milestones,
we've the ratification
of the 19th amendment,
as well as Martin Luther King's
March on Washington in 1963,
kind of the 57th anniversary of that.
And I'm also just curious about politics
and the operations of Congress generally.
But maybe what we'll
take it in that order.
- Sure.
- For young people watching,
and I don't think we get enough of this
when we watched the mainstream press,
they'll see folks like yourself,
who I've looked like
they've accomplished a lot
and have accomplished a lot.
And they're like, "How do I do that?
What are the steps that
I take in order to become
the next Karen Bass?"
(Karen laughing)
So as much as you can tell us about
what was your own journey,
maybe starting in middle and high school?
- Sure, well, first of
all, I will tell you that,
my journey, I never imagined
that I would be a member of
Congress, that's most important,
but I did decide at a very
young age that I really wanted
to focus on improving the quality of life
and addressing social and economic issues.
And that's because I
grew up in a time period
when all of that was happening,
post-civil rights, antiwar,
everything was exploding in the world,
and I was very captured by that.
And so it didn't occur to me
that I could actually make a living
and be politically involved.
And so I whipped down many paths,
one of which was the medical field.
So I worked in the medical
field, one is a nurse,
and then as a physician
assistant for a number of years,
and after work, I
volunteered in the community
and focused on different issues.
Now, ironically, given
what's happening today,
one of the first issues I
focused on was police abuse,
because we had terrible
problems in Los Angeles,
and we are on the heels within 24 hours
of two terrible shootings
that took place in two different states.
So many decades later the
issues are still the same.
And after a while I started
a community organization
that was also focused on these issues,
and from there ran for office.
But I did not set out to say,
"I wanna be an elected official."
- And to any young people out there.
I think there's kind of two
categories of young people,
there's those who are
idealistic, and they say,
"I could run for office
and I could play a role in civic change."
And it could be as being
an elected official,
it could be in other ways.
But there's also increasing cynicism
about politics and polarization,
and I wanna talk more about that.
But just from your point of view,
what would you tell a young person?
Who's right there, are they both right?
Is there a way to have
a more idealistic track
in politics and policy?
- Well, I think they both are right.
And I went through periods
where I felt cynical as well,
but cynical about what?
I've never felt cynical about people
and people's ability
to bring about change.
But one thing about politics
is that there's so many ways
to get involved in being an
office is just one of them.
And so when I went through a period
where I was pretty cynical,
I was involved on a community level,
and I wasn't interested
in elected politics.
That's why I said I never
imagined myself being in Congress.
But I think at a certain point in time,
if you're really committed to change,
then you wanna see something happen.
And so getting involved
in a community level,
I did that first, and then I was working
with elected officials
to bring about change,
and then ultimately decided
to go in on that path myself.
But let me just say
that if you are cynical
and if you make the choice
to not be involved at all,
then you are essentially
allowing other people
to control your life,
and I think that's an
important decision to make.
Do you want to be in the driver's seat
or do you wanna be in the passenger seat?
And regardless of whether you
choose to be involved or not,
the powers that be will
be involved in your life.
So it's a question of whether or not
you wanna participate with them or not.
- And what advice would
you have for young people
who wanna be in that driver's seat,
or at least start exercising that muscle
of nudging their way
into the driver's seat?
What could what could they
start doing right now?
- Right now, you see the wonderful thing
about the generation of young
people that are watching this,
is that you have technology
that didn't always exist,
and so there's so many
ways to get involved now,
there's tons of organizations
that focus on different issues.
So what I always tell people is that,
where's your heart?
What really interests you?
Is it the environment?
Is it immigration?
Is race?
All so many different issues.
Find out an issue that interests you,
and then find out other people
that are involved in that issue,
because now with technology,
any issue you pick
there's millions of
people already involved.
- Absolutely, and I wanna
remind everyone watching,
you can put your questions
in the message boards
on YouTube and Facebook,
and we have team members
who will surface those
questions to Representative Bass
and to myself, and I'll try to get to
as many of those as, as possible.
- Can I add one other thing.
Is that it doesn't
matter what age you are.
I have worked with eight
year olds and nine year olds
who were interested in politics,
now today they're 20 year olds.
(Karen laughing)
So your age should not prohibit you
from being involved at all,
don't see that as a barrier.
- You know when you say
that, it reminds me,
I remember when I was, let's
call it 12 or 13 years old,
and you're pondering your
place in the universe.
And I always looked at people
who are 30, 40, 50, 60
years old, and I'm like,
they must have it all figured
out, they've been around
for so long.
- (laughs) right.
- The reality is adults
stop thinking about
a lot of this stuff,
a lot of kids actually
are deeper thinkers about
society than a lot of adults.
So kids don't feel insecure about that,
you have as much of a
right to have an opinion
about these things as anybody.
Given these anniversaries
we're going into,
which is always a time for reflection,
you have the hundred year
anniversary of the certification,
I guess the ratification
of the 19th Amendment,
giving women the right to
vote, 57th year anniversary of,
or about two on August 28 hit,
of the March on Washington.
You know, these are
related, you could argue,
but the women's right to vote
and participate in politics
is a civil rights issue,
and then you have obviously
the broader notion
of civil rights when it comes to race,
and these feel very connected.
Where do you think, and
you can take them separate
or intermingled these
two, where do you think
we are on that journey
in both women's rights
and civil rights in general?
- Well, let me just say, first of all,
that it is the 100th
anniversary, but it really
that when the 19th Amendment was signed,
it did not apply to all women,
so it only applied to white women.
Black women were not
allowed the right to vote,
neither were indigenous women
or women who were immigrants.
And so, um, it is an
anniversary to celebrate,
but I think it's an example
of how we have a rocky road.
I mean, we move forward,
there's some progress,
and then sometimes we have a move back.
So while we're celebrating
these anniversaries,
we are 69 days away
from the next election,
and everybody watching this
who is 18 years old and older,
I know you're registered to vote
and I know you plan to vote.
Even in 2020, we still
have to deal with the fact
that people in the United States
do not automatically
have the right to vote.
Because now there are tactics
that are done, voter suppression.
So the latest area that we
have to be concerned about
is the post office and COVID.
So here we have an election 69 days away,
and people are worried
about going out to vote
because they might get exposed to COVID,
and in some States they're
not gonna make it easy
for people to vote from home.
And so 2020, we are still
fighting some of the same issues,
there has been progress,
but one thing we've learned
from the last few years is
that you can make progress,
but that doesn't mean it's permanent,
you always have to be
vigilant and stay on it
because the progress you
made can be reversed.
- And from your point of
view, I mean, I'm curious,
the voter suppression
tactics over the years,
obviously if you go back decades,
you had things like poll
tests and things like that.
Do you think that we're kind
of in some ways reverting,
I mean, some of this conversation
with the post office,
I mean, you're much closer
to the issue than I am.
I mean, what is going on?
I mean, one view is, does
it hurt everyone equally?
And so maybe it doesn't,
- No.
- Have a dramatic outcome.
I'd love to hear your thoughts.
- Sure, sadly to say that
voter suppression tactics
are very targeted and they're targeted
to communities of color,
they're also targeted to
young people and to students.
And so the form that voter suppression
has taken over the last few years,
and this is all because the Supreme Court
did a headache decision a few years ago
that essentially pulled the teeth
out of the Voting Rights Act.
And one of the main accomplishments
of the civil rights movement
was the Voting Rights Act,
which protected the
right to vote initially
for black people, but also
for other people of color,
where in the South in particular,
but this also happens around the country,
but in the South black people
had to risk their lives
to go vote, and sometimes
they had to suffer violent consequences.
And so the federal
government had to step in
to protect the right to vote.
While the Supreme Court a few years ago
really kind of undid that.
And so the minute the Supreme
Court made that decision,
within hours of that decision being made,
many States imposed
very strong restrictions
that limited the right to
vote for certain people.
- One thing I'm curious,
as a member of Congress
you obviously interact a lot with people,
Congress members from throughout
the country of both parties,
and actually you have a reputation
of being very well liked
and respected by both sides of the aisle.
When you talk to folks
who are on the other side
and you bring up these
issues, are they kind of like,
Yeah, this is a real issue,
but there's all this
political gamesmanship
to try to make the numbers
work for one side or the other,
or do you feel that they're
just not seeing the issue?
- Well, I know my colleagues see
the issue there, they're smart.
(Karen laughing)
The sad thing is that people
in power wanna stay in power,
they wanna stay in office.
And so what they tend to say
is they tend to talk about voter fraud,
and that they're protecting
against voter fraud.
The problem is, is that there
is just virtually no evidence
that voter fraud is a very big problem.
As a matter of fact, the
most significant voter fraud
that took place in 2018
took place in North Carolina
and it was done by Republicans.
So one thing that you learn about
when you serve in a legislative body,
whether that's local state or federal,
is you learn to compartmentalize.
So there are some subjects, some issues
that I work very well with
my Republican colleagues on,
and then there's some issues
that we don't talk about
because we know we have
diametrically opposing views.
But important is is that
whether you agree or disagree,
there's no reason at all
not to be respectful and
nice to the other side.
So I might disagree with
them terribly on one issue,
but then 10 other issues we agree on.
And so you tend to
focus where you can work
and compartmentalize where you can't.
- It makes a ton of sense,
and I actually have more
questions about Congress.
But a really good question
from YouTube came up
from Rupesh Cathy, says,
"Representative Bass,
the racial discrimination
has been such a main issue
in recent years, but it
seems like we're seeing
the same results over and over.
How do we really improve it?"
- Well, actually we have suffered terribly
over these last three and a half years,
because we have someone at
the top who's pretty open
about his feelings about other people.
But at the same time, because he has been
(Karen laughing)
so divisive, let me
say, it's allowed people
to see race in another way, and
I'm actually very encouraged
after the horrible murder of George Floyd,
that there is a new awareness
in our country about racism.
What we have tended to do in our country
is we only like the good
part of our history,
we don't wanna hear the
bad news, and so it's hard
for people to accept that slavery existed
in this United States for over 200 years,
250 years to be exact,
100 years before the
country was actually formed.
And so we don't wanna talk
about these difficult subjects like race.
But I feel like, especially
with the younger generation,
there is an openness now to
say there is discrimination
within the institutions of our society,
let's examine where the
discrimination exists
and let's get rid of it.
And I'm hopeful that
we're about to approach
a new milestone in our
history, but we are going
to have to have new leadership at the top
in order for that to take place.
- And where do you think
the rubber hits the road?
Clearly what happens at the
national level sets a tone,
kind of sets a context in
which everything happens.
But when we talk, think
about George Floyd's murder,
that seems like a local
police reform issue,
although it seems like
it's somewhat systemic
across many geographies.
What levers do you have in
Congress or at the federal level?
And then what are the other levels?
Is it mayors?
Is it police commissioners?
Or is it something else
that changes things?
- Sure, it is all of the above,
and I would encourage your listeners
to watch a documentary on
Netflix that's called "13th."
It's about the 13th Amendment.
Watch that documentary
because it goes through
the history of policing
in the United States.
So this has long been an issue,
especially with African Americans.
And I think that, uh, every
level of government is involved.
So the rubber meets the
road on the federal level,
because the federal government
has the purse strings.
We control the money, which
is given out on a local level.
The locals are important
because they implement and set policy.
So after George Floyd's murder,
we pass legislation in the house.
Now it stalled in the Senate.
But the good news is,
just the mere fact of us
going about introducing
legislation, led to many states
and cities and counties, also
moving ahead in advance of us
and passing their own legislation
to outlaw things like choke-holds,
where a police officer can
choke somebody to death,
or a no-knock, which Brianna Taylor died
when her door was smashed in,
and the officers were in the wrong house.
Now it's unveiled that
they've done that before,
and they shot her, here
she's in bed asleep.
So there are certain
practices that police have
that make it very difficult
to sue police officers,
to fire them or to prosecute them.
That's why the man that
was killing George Floyd
on video was looking dead at the camera,
he wasn't worried because he knew
he could act with complete impunity.
We need to change those laws,
so officers cannot act
with complete impunity.
- And that's just one dimension of kind of
this ongoing movement
towards racial equality,
and we also talk about gender equality.
What are, if you could wave a magic wand
from a legislative point of view
or our other points of
view, what are the things
that we should be striving for,
we should be working for, forward towards?
- Well, first of all, in
the environment of COVID,
I am extremely concerned about
the disproportionate death rate
amongst communities of color
and, and healthcare, that's one.
I'm also because of COVID very concerned
about education and the achievement gap,
a great role of Khan Academy complaint.
Is that many households do not necessarily
have the technology or
the parents aren't there,
especially with young children
because they're essential workers.
We already have an achievement gap
between kids of color and white children.
Well now, with COVID, I'm concerned that
that achievement gap is
going to be really increased,
and so we need to think about that
when we're past this pandemic.
And then of course the entire
criminal justice system,
which involves policing on one end,
is that we have more
prisoners in the United States
by proportion than any
other country in the world.
There's just no reason for
that, especially because
the vast majority of people
that are incarcerated
are poor people who can't afford bail,
and that is one of the big
reasons why they're locked up,
this just shouldn't exist in our country.
- Absolutely, I mean, there's
these three dimensions,
there's kind of the
criminal justice system,
there's education that you just mentioned,
and obviously that's where
we are trying our best, you're right,
we're part of a much bigger ecosystem.
And then there's the economy,\.
Where are we right when COVID hit,
and we had the shutdowns
of some form in society,
Congress, and I would say,
and the executive branch,
everyone was fairly fast to pass
these first few stimulus bills.
Now it seems like things
are a little bit more stuck
maybe cause we're getting
close to the election.
What do you think is the right thing
that needs to happen given
the moment that we're in?
- And actually because
we're near an election,
you would think that they
would be fast forward,
the right thing to do always
is to protect people, period.
And so the idea that we passed the bill
over a hundred days ago, that's
languishing in the Senate.
People lost their unemployment
insurance several weeks ago.
People need stimulus checks.
One of the things holding up the bill
is that some of my colleagues feel,
if we give a $600 check a week to people
that that will be a disincentive
for them to go to work.
That hurts my heart, considering
that we passed legislation
that gave half a trillion dollars
to major businesses like
the airlines and the hotels.
Now I'm fine with that,
but just like we need to bail them out,
we need to bail the average
citizen out as well.
The other thing is, is that
we have 178,000, thousand,
Americans that died in
the last four months.
And I don't believe
that they needed to die
if we had dealt with
the pandemic correctly.
So we need money for testing,
for tracing and for treatment.
All of those things are in the bill
that has been sitting in
the Senate for a 100 days.
- And I'll add to that, we had Ray Dalio,
famed hedge fund manager,
runs the largest hedge fund
in the world, who clearly has
a very deep understanding of economics.
And sometimes the left,
right argument is stereotyped
as the left will say, "Oh,
we need more supports.
We need to support people."
And the right would say,
"Well, the incentives
that might create, or that
might drive inflation."
But we're in an emergency
where people essentially
can't work, none of their own choice.
- Right.
- And deflation is our biggest risk,
interest rates are at an all time low.
And Ray Dalio in his own words who,
I wouldn't call him a political ideolog
by any stretch of the
imagination of saying,
"There's really no better option."
And this was a conversation
about two months ago.
- Yeah.
- But clearly,
we're getting in a place where
the economy is sputtering,
and the most obvious thing do frankly,
regardless of what side
of the aisle you're on
is to just to make sure that
that fuel keeps circulating.
So just me as my economics
teacher, it makes a lot of sense.
(Karen laughing)
- Well, and I don't understand,
I mean, exactly what you
said, we are near an election.
So you would think that everyone
would want to make sure that
communities have support.
So I am baffled by that,
when I don't understand
why my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle
in the Senate are holding up the bill.
And you know, we've talked about COVID,
we've talked about kind of the progression
or a little bit of the
progression on civil rights issue.
On where women are,
especially women in politics
or women in society, clearly
there's a lot of progress
that has been made over
the last hundred years.
You are in a position of you are
one of the most influential
Congress people,
we now have Kamala Harris
as the vice presidential
nominee on a major ticket.
Is this the beginning?
Are we going to get to
a new inflection point?
Or is this more superficial
and there's still
some deep seated things
that we need to fix?
- I think it's also all of the above.
I mean, I do think that Kamala Harris,
and hopefully our side will be successful
and it will be Biden-Harris
sworn in in January,
that's huge, that's breaking
a glass ceiling that is major.
And so I think that that's important.
On the other hand, we still
need to pass legislation
for the Equal Rights Amendment.
We need to amend the
constitution for pay equity,
all of those things.
So we still have a ways to
go, but it is very important
just as you said, it's so important
to acknowledge progress, because otherwise
that adds two sentences.
When people say, well, I
haven't seen major change,
it's always important
to understand history,
because if you know history
and understand history,
then you can see how things do change.
And that's why we need
everybody that's watching
to make sure that they
one vote in 69 days,
make sure you fill out your census form
and then stay involved,
stay involved, we need you.
And maybe the last thing,
right before we went
live on this live stream,
you and I were talking a little bit about,
all of us were having to work
on video conferencing now.
And I am curious about Congress itself,
I read this, I read a lot
of science fiction books,
a lot of them were behind me right now.
But there's alternative models
of representative democracies.
Obviously ours is based on geography,
because we didn't have even telephones
when our government was architected.
Do you think that there's gonna be things
that come out of this crisis
or even new ways of working
that actually might alter
Congress as a whole.
And I'm also curious, we touched on
kind of the polarization a little bit.
Is it as bad as it looks from the outside?
And what is the cure for that?
- Sure, well, first of all,
I do think it's gonna alter
our way of functioning, period.
And not just in Congress,
I think all of us are
gonna be different now.
And there's some good things about it,
good things about it in terms of Zoom,
in your ability to interact
with lots of people online.
But in terms of the
polarization, I think that,
I mean, I hate to say it this
way, but on the one hand,
you see what you see from
us on TV is theater, okay?
We don't hate each other.
We actually do work together.
We do disagree on some things,
but there's lots of things we agree about.
It's just that it tends that
that's not really newsworthy,
so you don't hear when
we actually do things,
and that needs to change.
But I think the polarization,
we need to have a less divisive leader.
Let me leave it at that.
- Okay, and you know, the last point,
I mean, you mentioned what
we have to do in education.
I completely agree with you,
and I wrote an op-ed in
New York times last week,
we can't let this education crisis
turned to an education catastrophe,
for all the reasons that you mentioned,
where the kids who are
already not fully resourced
are now the ones the most
likely to either not have access
or when they do, they don't have
the right supports, et cetera, et cetera.
What could we do at Khan Academy?
What advice do you have for us?
And I also want advice
because a lot of folks
have been telling us, you'll have
to work more closely with government,
in a lot of ways the work
that Khan Academy is doing
is maybe somewhat a role of government.
- Yes.
- How should we navigate this?
(both laughing)
- I think that's absolutely right.
And you do play a tremendous role
and it's a tremendous benefit to people.
And maybe the way in terms of coordinating
with government might be the case.
And I think you becoming,
the Khan Academy becoming
more well known, certainly
within the halls of Congress,
there's people that know
and people that don't.
And like I mentioned to you before,
two of my staff members have
benefited by Khan Academy,
you help them with calculus.
And with me, I mentioned to you
that I have used Khan Academy with adults
who've experienced health crisis,
like a heart issue, for example,
and really didn't understand
how the heart worked.
And so it's very helpful
in a variety of ways.
- Now, I have to tell you,
I think it was about
four or five years ago,
I got separately invited
to the House Republican Caucus retreat
and the House democratic Caucus retreat,
this was like a year apart.
And when I presented, folks were like,
"Wow, what kind of games to trying to do
represents what our
party is trying to do."
And both parties separately said this.
So I feel like we might
be threading the needle
on a bipartisan issue, so I
would love to work with you,
to figure out how we can
especially reach the kids
that need this most right now.
And I 100% agree, a lot
of it could be free,
it's just amplification.
There's a lot of folks who
know about Khan Academy,
but there's a lot of folks
who could know about it,
who aren't benefiting fully just yet.
- Exactly, and so you know what?
I'm gonna go back and
tell our new caucus chair,
you need to come back to
our retreat next year.
(both laughing)
- Sounds good, I'd
probably be less traveled,
we'll probably be on Zoom.
So hopefully we're through
through the crisis by then.
Any last parting words of advice
for kids who are watching,
who are just trying to absorb everything
we just talked about?
- Just that the most important
thing is to be healthy,
to be safe, to abide by the
public health requirements,
and make sure that your parents
fill out that census form,
and just remember you are
never, never, never too young
to get involved in politics
and community issues,
there's always room for you.
- Well, thank you so
much Representative Bass,
this was an inspiring conversation.
I say it every time, these
conversations go way faster
than I expect, because
they're so interesting,
but thank you for taking out the time,
at a time that I know is very busy
and a lot of important things going on.
- My pleasure, thank you.
- Well, thanks everyone
again for participating.
I continue to be very impressed
with everyone that we talk to,
and especially Representative Bass,
I find to be a very inspiring figure.
But thanks for joining, hopefully
you got some good advice,
hopefully we do figure out a way
to work with Congress in some way
to be able to support more folks
as we go through this crisis
and then beyond the crisis.
And I hope to see all of y'all tomorrow,
where we're gonna be doing
another a Homeroom live stream,
and this will just be one of
our classic Ask Sal Anythings.
So I really look forward to that,
that's always a fun thing for
me to just ask me anything.
And so start thinking of your questions,
and I'm literally happy to
answer a question about anything,
I'm very hard to offend or surprise.
So I will see y'all tomorrow.
(upbeat music)